at each turning point it gets worse
mystery virus they'd hoped to contain
but one we now know can jump from human
to human at a time when humans are
uniquely on the move hundreds of
millions of people are making journeys
around the country for Chinese New Year
take us a canoe of course I'm worried
and the virus may spread further all of
a sudden a cross infection happens
during this spring travel period the
epidemic will be terrible and if China
sneezes the world is worried about
catching more than a cold International
Airport's like this one in Tokyo already
taking pre-emptive measures to prevent
the spread in Hong Kong the lessons of
the SARS epidemic of 2002 to 2003 means
scientists understand the potential
danger of this virus which is a close
relative it is absolutely critical that
public health authorities recognize a
super spreading event in the very
earliest stages before it goes
absolutely explosive SARS killed nearly
800 people and it still cast the shadow
Chinese authorities covered up the scale
of the epidemic and took two months to
give access to experts from the World
Health Organization not this time though
according to the same organization China
quickly identified this new virus and
shared genetics genetics sequence with
with everyone else which helped other
countries to put diagnostic tests
chinese state media has also put the
story front and center and the president
xi jinping has made a personal statement
vowing to curb the spread of the mystery
virus overnight really the leadership
here in beijing and chinese state media
has gone into overdrive what they're
doing is try and demonstrate the work
that is already been carried out
according to outside experts to combat
this epidemic but they're also trying to
reassure a Chinese public that is
skeptical if not downright distrustful
of how government handles these sort of
crises especially after the SARS
epidemic and beyond that doing
everything they can to prevent a panic
the World Health Organization will meet
tomorrow to discuss whether the outbreak
should be declared an international
health emergency but it will take much
longer weeks even months to know the
scale of this epidemic
Tom Cheshire Sky News Beijing